North Korea says it has test-fired a new
tactical guided weapon that's according
to the country's state news agency it
did not specify what the weapon is but
analysts say it did not appear to be a
banned ballistic missile the agency said
North Korean leader Kim jong-un observed
the test firing North Korea and the US
have been engaged in talks over
Pyongyang's nuclear program but those
negotiations have stalled in recent
months let's bring in journalist Kelly
Casula she's standing by in Seoul
following this story hi Kelly has there
been any more information on what type
of weapon has been tested if there was a
test you know right now the South Korean
government has said that they're still
analyzing this alleged weapons past you
know lastly heard is three or four hours
ago there have been you know some minor
analysis done and that there's no
evidence right now of nuclear activity
or of it being an intercontinental
ballistic missile which is the kind of
thing that United States and South Korea
would feel really threatened by yeah if
this analysis does confirm that there
was a test it would though be the first
public weapons tests since nuclear talks
between the north and the u.s. ended
without an agreement what do you think
that's going to mean for relations
between the two n efforts towards
disarmament you know it certainly won't
be great for talks between North Korea
and the United States I mean as it is
already since the Vietnam summit it
seems like dialogue and diplomacy has
been somewhat unraveling even though
both countries have expressed some good
faith some people are starting to say
that you know this could be assigned to
President Trump that Kim Jungman the
leader of North Korea is serious about
the deadline he's set in terms of
talking about trade-offs for US
sanctions by the end of the year
personally I think that you know it's
not a fantastic development but at the
same time there was a similar alleged
weapons test in November of last year
and that has happened you know after
this initial set of diplomacy between
North Korea in the United States so
we'll just have to wait all right
journalists Kelly Casillas were talking
to us from Seoul thank you very much